عند حدوث زلزال فجاه بدات الاهتزازات على
هذه الحاله استيقظنا احتضن اطفالنا وقمنا
بالركض ونحن ندعو الله كانت الاهتزازات لا
تنتهي حقيقه شيء يصعب شرحه الله لا يبتلي
احدا بهذا المصاب عندما غادرنا البناء
بدات الهزات الارتداديه بعد عده دقائق
حينها ركضنا في الشارع وكان الجميع في
حاله هلعه كان شعورا سيئا للغايه
عندما جلبت اقربائي من منطقه نورداك في
ولايه غاز عنتاب بعد حدوث الزلزال كان
امامنا ثلاث حافلات تقل الجيش والشرطه كان
هناك هطول الامطار والثلوج لذلك ساعدونا
في الوصول استغرق الطريق 16 ساعه علما انه
يستغرق عاده ساعتين
الا من برلين وجئت لمساعده اصدقائي هنا
وانقاذ الناس ابني ايضا جاء معي للمساعده
وهو يعمل مع فرق متطوعين انا اسكن في
الطابق الاول عند حدوث الزلزال خرجنا الى
الشارع بسرعه في منطقه ينيبي كان مشهدا
مخيفا اطلب والد زوجه طيفون ايدوغان
وزوجته عائشه واولادهما ثلاثه كانوا
يعيشون في هذا المبنى وجميعهم تحت الانقاض
حاليا لم نستطع الوصول اليهم حتى اللحظه
ما تزال اعمال الانقاذ مستمره ونحن لم
نفقد الامل بعد